dernier coup de pelle avant l'arrivée
des enfants dans cette cour d'école
entièrement rénové de la pelouse des
arbres et insolent respirant voilà ce
que découvriront dans une semaine les
élèves qui ont contribué à cette
métamorphose
c'était un projet participatif ça
c'était très important pour nous pour
que les enfants se sentent investis de
leur cour de récréation et que vraiment
y voit le changement cette année lors de
la rentrée des pavés à joindre et non du
sable stabilisé ou encore des copeaux de
bois
les enfants profiteront dans cette cour
d'un sol qui respire loin du bitume qui
l'ont connu auparavant
aujourd'hui l'idée c'est d'infiltrer
l'eau et de plus planter les cours
d'école à ceva là pour les cours d'école
mais c'est valable aussi pour toutes les
villes où pour tous les endroits de la
ville pour éviter les îlots de chaleur
il faut des matériaux claire des
matériaux drainants est planté beaucoup
plus dans un programme a prévu sur dix
ans la ville de dijon souhaite reverdir
plus de cour d'école un plan coûteux
pour la municipalité
ces trois cent cinquante mille euros
donc vous imaginez on a 80 deux écoles
donc vous imaginez le coût que ça
pourrait représenter donc toutes ne sont
pas à vaiges et alizée y en a qui le
sont déjà fort heureusement mais celle
là va être exemplaire et à partir de
celle là bas on va voir ce qu'on peut
faire avec les autres dans sept autres
établissements les efforts se sont
portés sur la performance énergétique du
bâtiment grâce à ses panneaux solaires
40% d'économie d'énergie sont attendus
mais pour cet élu de l'opposition la
municipalité manque d'ambition dans son
programme ce qu'on aimerait en revanche
on a un peu déçu c'est ça aille plus
vite plus loin plus fort quitte à
apprendre des éléments à picorer dans le
programme autant prendre l'intégralité
du programme écologiste dans lequel il y
avait une végétalisation du centre-ville
pas simplement des écoles mais des
centres-villes un centre ville où les
habitants aimeraient aussi profiter un
jour d' îlots de fraîcheur ailleurs que
sous les parasols